[Music]
bringing back dinosaurs would probably
end in an unfortunate outcome as the
jurassic park franchise has shown us
countless times so i think most of us
would agree that while resurrecting
dinosaurs through some miraculous future
technology would be cool it's almost
certainly not a good idea but i can't
deny i've still always been interested
in the concept of a responsibly run
prehistoric reserve where nothing goes
wrong and the dinosaurs don't eat you
that's the basic concept behind the
fictional park of prehistorica a
biological nature preserve where
resurrected dinosaurs and other
prehistoric animals are treated with
care and the fences actually work
prehistorica is a world building project
created by joshua dunlop a talented
artist and creator who you can follow
and support in the links below and since
we sadly can't truly visit prehistorica
for this entry into the archive i'll be
taking on the role of tour guide and
giving you a glimpse of the well-managed
prehistoric reserve that i think we've
all secretly wanted to vacation at the
fictional reserve is set in the future
on an enormous artificial island aptly
named pangea the island supports over 20
different biomes including tropical and
subtropical rainforests deserts
mountains tundra woodlands grasslands
mangroves and more all of which are home
to a variety of prehistoric life our
tour will take us across the entire
island and we'll learn quite a bit about
the species here along the way so get
ready to discover the wonders of a world
lost to time
welcome to taurosaurus trail the first
stop on our tour
here you can drive through the vast open
plains in an autonomous vehicle and get
a close look at the one and only
taurosaurus herd these large frilled
herbivores have grown accustomed to the
armored viewing vehicles and will often
lumber close by them allowing for some
exciting close encounters and next to
these vehicles it's easy to appreciate
how large even the newborns can get
while you observe these magnificent
creatures a park ranger might point out
the difference between triceratops and
taurosaurus some scientists have
actually theorized the larger
taurosaurus is actually just the adult
form of triceratops although more recent
studies indicate they're in fact a
distinctive genus if unique taurosaurus
had one of the largest skulls of any
known land animal fascinating stuff away
from the plains in the misty jungles of
majungasaurus mountains you'll have the
opportunity to see some truly mighty
theropods from an underground viewing
station you can get up close and
personal with the only majungasaurus
pack on prehistorica right now it's
feeding time and dinner is being
delivered in from above by custom drones
that lower the specialized lab-grown
meat safely into the majungasaurus
habitat which is a vast region that like
most environments is sectioned off with
advanced futuristic barriers to ensure
the dinosaurs don't eat each other or
eat park guests while you watch the
majungasaurus pack chow down on their
air delivered meal you might be
interested to learn their teeth are
serrated and they have more teeth than
most genuses in their family these
fearsome fangs likely helps
majungasaurus take down small sauropods
like rapetosaurus a theory supported by
majungasaurus tooth marks on some
repetosaurus fossils
down the mountain you can take a stroll
through the calming temperate
kentrosaurus woodland where you might
spot some gentle giants this unique
genus of stegosaurid herbivores is
incredibly well mannered but can be a
little clumsy with the large pointed
spikes on their bodies which help defend
them from predators so it's best to view
the kentrosaurus from a safe distance on
one of the many elevated viewing
platforms and if you're wondering about
the spikes we can theorize from real
fossils that kentrosaurus had long
pointed spikes in the back transitioning
into shorter and flatter plates near the
front with 15 pairs in total in short
kentrosaurus was likely a very well
defended dinosaur
if you're not afraid of a little
adventure you can jump on a guideboat
and make your way down the muddy
diabloceratops river here you might be
able to spot a diabloceratops wading
through the slow-moving waters to cool
off in the hot afternoon sun to ensure
these animals aren't pulled out of their
natural rhythms however the tour boats
don't get too close it's worth noting
the concept of diabloceratops wading in
rivers like a hippopotamus is purely
speculative since diabloceratops likely
lived in a region full of lakes and
floodplains during the cretaceous it's a
logical guess that a good wallowing
would keep these horn-faced herbivores
comfortable further down river the tour
boats drift around the band of sukomai
miss stream a region where you might
just see some of prehistorica's
river-dwelling carnivores believe it or
not the animal you see here is just a
juvenile and the adults get considerably
larger but don't worry the artist states
these water giants can't get too close
to the boat thanks to an invisible fence
system and non-intrusive underwater
barriers that keep their toothy jaws far
away from park visitors some
paleontologists believe psukomimus is a
variant of the better known baryonyx if
unique psucomimus was likely larger than
its cousin with some estimates reaching
34 feet or 10.3 meters in length in the
author notes specimens of baryonyx can
also be found on prehistorica just in a
separate region as both species are
quite territorial
venturing all the way out to the
tropical coast there's an opportunity to
get a bird's eye view of the island of
pangaea if you take a ride in a coastal
sky box you'll get not only a view of
the stunning cerulean waters but might
also catch a glimpse of some of
prehistorica's flying pterosaur species
the artist imagines the various
pterosaurs of prehistorica aren't
contained in an aviary but are allowed
to nest freely on the coast thanks to
each one being fitted with a tracker
real world pterosaur fossils have been
found in an incredible number of
locations all over the globe as this
order was extremely diverse and
successful when first discovered people
in the 18th and 19th century were
baffled by these remains and some
theorized pterosaurs were actually a
lost order of flying marsupials today we
of course know better although it's
important to note that despite a common
misconception
pterosaurs are an order altogether
separate from dinosaurs
on a state-of-the-art ferry you can tour
archelon harbor or if you're feeling
adventurous you can grab yourself a
kayak and get even closer to some
incredible marine prehistoric life if
you pedal near the shallow waters of the
coastal islands you can watch our kellon
turtles glide beneath your boat these
enormous life forms might be a little
intimidating due to their sheer size but
arcelon turtles are actually some of the
most docile and friendly creatures in
all of prehistorica and i have to say
looking at this scene in particular it's
hard not to wish this was a real place
you could visit real world archelon
weren't quite as big as prehistorica's
reconstructions which the author notes
aren't always a hundred percent accurate
but they got pretty close with some
fossils measuring 15 feet or 4.5 meters
in length not surprisingly sea turtles
were once thought to be arcelon's
closest living relatives but now
scientists theorize archelon might
actually have been a completely separate
lineage
heading back inland you can make your
way down to plesiosaur pond through
underground viewing zones you and your
family can take in the many species from
the plesiosaur order that whole
prehistoric other home and according to
the artist might even get a chance to
feed them with a park ranger's
assistance of course
one neat fact to know about plesiosaurs
before you toss some food their way is
that plesiosaur fossils were found as
far back as the 19th century one of the
most important early specimens was found
by marianning a pioneering english
paleontologist who made vital
contributions to the field though sadly
never got the credit she deserved in her
lifetime recently however the plesiosaur
genus anning soria was named in her
honor the sun is now getting low but we
still have time for a few more stops
here at prehistorica in the fictional
brachiolophosaurus badlands if you come
at the right time you could be some of
the lucky few who gets to see the first
interaction between a brachylophosaurus
hatchling and the rest of their herd
these beak dinosaurs are elegant and
peaceful making these first meetings a
beautiful experience for the guests who
get to see one millions of years after
going extinct these remarkable creatures
are resuming these ancient cycles of
life
some real braculofasaurus specimens are
notable for being exceptionally well
preserved with some remains of these
mid-sized hadrosaurids possessing skin
impressions and even the remains of what
they recently ate examining the contents
of their stomach it seems their diet
included leaves conifers ferns and
flowering plants and we can assume
prehistorica caretakers are feeding them
their favorites
and finally as the sun sets on the
island of pangaea we'll make our last
stop on this tour millions of years in
the making
the brachiosaur redwoods are home to a
wide range of species the largest of
which is the titular brachiosaurus herd
these titanic sauropods occupy a large
area and migrate each day to a lake
where they enjoy a swim before moving to
the redwoods to graze the artist
imagines you can view this vast herd
from treetop walkways which would be an
incredible sight while you watch the
brachiosaurus munch on vegetation you
might be interested to learn that these
world famous sauropods have been
estimated at over 66 feet or 20 meters
in length and might have weighed more
than 12 african elephants a seriously
impressive genus to end our tour
though the sun has set on prehistorica
you can check out the work of the
talented creator joshua dunlop using the
links in the description below also
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
entry you can help make these videos
possible by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
you